- [Mark] All right, Caroline.
Welcome back.
- Hello.
- [Mark] How's everything?
- [Caroline] I'd say exciting
day in a sense, just-
- [Mark] What's going on?
- And just a relief trying to figure out
who connected onto my
spleen as well as my name.
Some people might not understand that
but it's a development
just happening right now
and there's a movies set over there.
So I happen to think they
have something to do with it.
Also, I wanted to say one thing,
everybody that gets paranoid,
and you feel like you're crazy and stuff,
just let that go when you hear this.
Try to let that go into the environment
because the paranoia should be in the land
where it's supposed to be.
But what I was saying
is they hooked onto my spleen
and they'd been doing
stuff using my spleen.
Well, I was put into a position of power
and they call it a holy figure, I guess,
or maybe even over that
or it might be the organizer of it all.
I don't really know,
but I know that it exceeds
a lot of holiness.
With that said,
your spleen is what
judges your sins
and different things like that.
So with them hooking onto
my spleen and my name,
they've developed trying to act like me
and it's really scary
'cause they've done a lot
of bad stuff in the world.
And so I'm just praying right now
that they would come clean
off my spleen and off my name
and off my genitals and my fertility
and my brain.
I've been connecting up to above,
which is a big deal.
Whoever helped me be able
to turn my right head
and it feels like my nose
or something breaks open
but they're intercepting stuff on my...
When I say prayers and
stuff and everybody's-
- [Mark] Caroline?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Tell me what
your daily routine is.
- My daily routine, I wake up-
- [Mark] Sometimes you wake up
right on the sidewalk right
in front of my studio.
- Sometimes I wake up in random places
'cause I don't wanna sleep in my tent
'cause I have so many clothes in there
and I don't think it's their fault
but people people pay money or...
Yeah, they pay money or
they do favors whatever
to be connected to the clothes in my tent.
And it's just gotten out of control
'cause with the antichrist and the cults,
and the masons,
I think it has a lot to
do with mason, masonic.
- [Mark] One time I came
here on a Saturday morning,
I think it was, and you just had a pillow
and you were just
sleeping on the sidewalk.
- Yeah, sorry.
The pillow is a big deal.
I don't think I've had a good pillow
and people always bring pillows
and I thank them
but I don't know if I've ever
been able to use a pillow,
but I hope that whatever
pillows done right now,
it could just-
- [Mark] Or maybe it's a blanket,
I don't remember.
- Blankets and pillows.
- [Mark] After you wake up in the morning,
you typically do what?
- I get up.
I try to get a cup of coffee.
Hopefully, I have money.
Usually I don't, but I have
been lately a little bit more
'cause I got my stimulus
check, but now that's gone.
I go and try to get money.
- [Mark] When you say try to get money,
that means picking up dates?
- Yeah, picking up dates.
- [Mark] I've seen you pick up guys here
driving down around 7th Street.
- Picking up dates, which
I don't really wanna be.
But I feel like,
I don't know if I have the
energy to exert myself.
I'm just learning about
how they're taking energies
'cause they're really doing a lot to me.
It's overwhelming if you could see
the amount of,
and on your life too and
that you even get here
is beyond mean.
There's gotta be people
you don't even know about
that are helping you to even get near me.
And I know Mark really
wants to thank those people
'cause it's getting to the point
where they're trying to
kill the excitement too,
both me and Mark
probably have our own
separate feelings right now,
but I could feel him just go, boom.
That's something that's
really bothering me.
I know these people sweep on the sidewalk.
I can feel them sweeping in my body
and I know that has to
do with stealing from me.
- [Mark] Your drugs are still?
- Heroin and some crack.
- [Mark] That's it?
- Yeah, and I know that
there's tannin in the heroin
and they've been blocking.
I got the total
411 today.
They've been blocking every
single hit I've taken of heroin
and that stuff can really help
to get rid of this
technology and all this...
If I could show you a picture of today,
but they have my body in
so many different places
but if I cut every string
and said, "I'm right here,"
then I got this thing and
it would show you today-
- [Mark] Caroline, I hate
to keep interrupting you.
So your daughter is back in, is it Oregon?
- My daughter's in Malibu?
- [Mark] Oh, she's in Malibu?
- And my mom's in Seattle,
my sister-
- Seattle.
- Yeah, I hope she's doing good.
Every time I try to send her my love,
it's a constant thing.
These people are blocking it.
I hope that block goes to nowhere
and I hope she gets a
feel of that all the time
that I miss her and my thoughts
are with her every second
and all my kids
'cause I found out I have
a whole bunch of kids
'cause I've been living this life
and I don't even think I've been born,
but I'm here and it's like I've been born.
So I've tried to burst my,
say I'm getting born like
about six months ago.
I don't really know what's transpired
but I know I'm here and I'm still alive.
I don't know how many
places I'm asleep at.
Some are really big figure or you,
we could be really in a bad position now.
- [Mark] Are you happy?
- I'm happy about
hopefully these people get
unattached from my spleen
and for them to stop lying
about me and torturing people,
making it hard for people to get here
and people blocking.
Oh, just it's beyond.
- [Mark] I'm sure your
family kind of got involved
and tried to help you at one point.
- They've been blocking my family from...
I could tell by the look on
their face at certain times
that there's something going on
but now I can look back and go,
"Okay, there's been something
going on with my family."
So with the people that
are looking for my family,
I hope that right now
because I feel a clarity coming
through like an ocean rush
of cleaning, that they would
be able to locate them.
And I know these people have been lying
and acting and all the
acting that's been used,
every bit of acting that's been used,
and I need to engage my seriousness
on this whole answers.
If I had said I have all my seriousness on
where would that leave the answers
to people that are looking?
It's really screwed up
'cause it looks like I
don't care about my family
and it looks like a lot of
things, but I hope they all know
I love them more than air.
It's just there's is a lot of emotions.
- [Mark] You've been through a lot.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And we've known each
other for about 10 years now?
At least, maybe even 11.
- Maybe even more
but I came in contact with,
it could be my first born son.
Some people just, like I said,
people you don't even
know that go and do things
- cause they felt like I
was probably gonna die.
- [Mark] How many children do you have?
- I have two children and this-
- [Mark] And some imaginary ones.
- Imaginary.
- [Mark] Or whatever you call them.
- Yeah.
I feel like I got a lot of hope from them
and my other children around there too
that think that they
are not that important,
but they really are the same.
They're all the same importance.
There's certain people
that you can get around
that can bring you to different levels.
That's what it is
and I need that to end now. (weeping)
- [Mark] It's hard to
watch your deterioration
since I met you and you
were intelligent and cogent
and you were just playing around
with drugs and prostitution
and now it's turned into
something much more serious
and it's hard to watch.
I see you down here.
I feel like I know you
and I wanna help you
and I don't even know where to start.
I wanna kidnap you.
(Caroline laughs)
- [Caroline] That's the
thing that goes through
a lot of these people's mind.
I bet all of them are thinking,
"How can we kidnap her and never
let her get her life back?"
That's a fear.
- [Mark] No, I just don't
want you to get this life back
but I don't think it works that way.
- [Caroline] It's a big fear on my...
Well, I try
not to show my face
- You had some terrible things
going on with you when
you were very young.
- [Caroline] Yeah.
- [Mark] And they have
probably set the stage
for everything that we're seeing today.
- [Caroline] Yeah, and
probably might be you as well
and people are looking for answers.
Along with caring about Caroline,
it takes care of yourself.
Really, to care about yourself
and to try to help yourself
before you could help me
because you can't help me.
I just feel like people are twisted
but I know you've done a lot to help
and just maybe even your presence here.
Weird things happen for a reason
but I know in this room, I
don't hear it from the people
but I'm hearing it now,
which I'm really glad
that this room has been a godsend as well
in a big way.
- [Mark] Caroline, I wish
you, I don't know what.
You need another miracle
like Amanda is getting
or being offered at least
and we'll see if maybe
something comes along the lines,
someone that can help you.
- What's happened with Amanda?
- [Mark] Do you know Amanda,
the young black girl that
walks around barefoot?
- I know a couple people.
Well, what happened?
- [Mark] She in a rehab now,
a very nice rehab.
- Oh, cool.
- [Mark] She's gotta be there for a year
and if she escapes or
leaves or does anything
other than stay there for a year,
she goes to prison for three years.
- Okay, I hope Amanda stays.
- It's kind of connected
with that and-
- There's something going
on with my chin and my cheek
but I hope that Amanda stays
'cause I just felt that
I'm not a presence of my,
this whatever, supposed
to help people, chin help.
Not trying to be the boss.
I'm talking about helping
and I just felt that whole
connection there with my chin.
- [Mark] Yeah, but I think
you could use some help too.
- Yeah, I could.
- [Mark] All right, Caroline,
lovely seeing you again.
I see you often.
- Thank you.
I hope you know how much I appreciate you.
You probably don't know it
but I know that there's possession on you.
I feel like it's almost
like you guys need it
but you know it's bad.
There's a whole bunch of fucked up things
I know that are going
through your guys's head.
And I know these people
have been abused incredibly
from the time they were born.
Just even knowing it
can open up the door to
just these people going,
"Okay, I'm not the only one
"and that these people are all on my side
"and don't wanna see me go to hell."
I guess that's the brunt of it all,
is where are you gonna end up?
- [Mark] All right, Caroline.
You may Skid Row.
- Thank you.
- Caroline for ages it seems.
That felt good, just to
get that off my chest
about this spleen thing.
I got that off my chest.